the Joe Rogan experience I think I read
an article recently that Andrew yang was
kind of dragging Asian Americans back to
you know to the left but no remains to
be seen he just dropped out so yeah
nobody's out I wonder what's gonna
happen yeah I was bummed about that he
was my guy he has some really
interesting ideas he's so he's so open
minded you know his his perspectives are
so uniquely non-politician yeah yeah
anyway how refreshing to finally have
somebody scientifically and
technologically literate yes in
government yes
that was really my attraction to I know
what the basic [ __ ] intellectual duck
web choice either Hamlet LC was mm-hmm
but I really really liked him yeah this
whole thing is so strange it looks like
they're trying to [ __ ] Bernie over again
just like they did in 2016 they're just
that could we watch that coin flip over
and over again yesterday yeah from Iowa
we were like arrest that kid put him in
jail
that was an illegal coin flip another
terrible coin flip but the whole thing
is just so weird
it's a it's seeing it play out and
seeing it play out so transparently so
many what the conspiracies are like
about now they're they're kind of like
pitting mayor Pete against Bernie mm-hmm
he's talking [ __ ] about Bernie he is to
a Abood I yesterday right and then
birdie was talking about how many
billionaires so many billionaires donate
timaya Pete I was pretty good bringing
it's not that good and you yang 20/20
dropout fuel speculation on NY Oh mayor
of NYC holy [ __ ] he could do that he
could win that [ __ ] yeah actually he
would house mayor Pete is he still a
mayor yeah yes how you do that that's a
bit of a complaint that's just a giant
good plan did he do a great job as a
mayor he's like the bet did he clean up
all the problems of that city he's he's
done enough to make people notice but I
think the african-american community is
not happy about some issues he talks
really well and handsome and he's a
veteran those are good things they're
like [ __ ] run him rot him
but no people are really raking him over
the coals for apparently like his you
know again he's checked all the right
boxes Harvard McKinsey like he's too
perfect like he was 3d printed in the
DNC headquarters you know yes so people
are very concerned about that like it's
so funny how like this whole optics and
authenticity really
I bet for me that's why I like Andrew
Young he was if you hate politicians
which I do he's the least heart to hate
yes he's the one talking to him he's so
normal he's like a guy who runs some
tech company or something that's what he
feels like when I really yeah yeah and
we that's the thing like you know with
24 hour exposure or social media and new
cycle this kind of signal is so obvious
in a way that was never before right we
can see normal people now yes and we
know the difference between
grandstanding posturing and just like
this yeah so I mean I just but also
normal people don't want to do it you
know it's like the the whole thing of it
it's just so invasive right it should
disqualify anybody who wanted to do it
exactly but you know this is a system we
have we gotta do this better than China
right of course yeah right yeah yeah
absolutely as dirty as it is over here
it's still better than the alternatives
that we see elsewhere around the world
I'm hoping things just continue to get
better I'm hoping more you know more
people understand the mechanisms behind
the scenes and how all the stuff works
[Applause]